que je suis non voyant que j'ai ma
petite fille de 4 ans qu'il faut que
j'emmène à l'école il me dit non mais en
fait je suis malade je suis allergique
contre les chiens
l'argument est totalement fallacieux
parce que je l'ai entendu plusieurs fois
préalablement je lui précise quand même
qu'il sera sûr que je vais mettre le
chien dans le coffre je sais la
contrainte que cela représente pour un
chauffeur que de nettoyer spontanément
je propose à tous les chauffeurs que le
chien aille dans le coffre
il y a pas de souci vas-y à ce moment je
me dis bon ça y est en fait il nous
prend il va ouvrir donc à la grand-mère
et à ma fille de l'autre côté je fais
monter le chien côté passager
quoi il est persuadé que c'est moi qui
l'ai agressé
il faut savoir que ce monsieur porter
plainte contre moi pour violence